assuming you can trust anything stored
in a database
a little disconcerting at a data
conference but i get the i get the
sentiment
his family tree can be traced back as
far as 600 a.d
so i think we've got to find out where
it's going at 600 a.d
how much of his family trees like one
little line is like a whole big
forest of trees and i want to know
where were you in 600 a.d uh what
continent what country what were you
doing i'm very fascinated by this so
everyone please welcome to the stage
will
well thank you jared if anyone has read
robert heinlein novels at any point
my family has always felt to me like the
howard family foundation
but in a good non-suicidal sort of way
there exists a doan family foundation
currently housed at doane university in
nebraska
and their job for the past few hundred
years has been to record
who begat whom um so they have they have
very good records
uh going back to uh pre-plymouth colony
and
to our european origins my name is will
doan
i am a research staff member at the
science and technology policy institute
which normally i say most people have
never heard of
but in dc you may well have heard of us
we are located in downtown washington dc
uh
opposite corner from the eisenhower
executive office building
we are a federally funded research and
development center i'll say a little bit
more about what that means
in a moment um we were established by
the united states congress back in the
1990s
and are currently managed by the
institute for defense analyses ida
previously we were managed by
rand up until around the turn of the
century
i am sorry we are our task our charter
is to support the white house office of
science and technology policy
and the president's council of advisors
on science and technology or pcast as
it's known
we also take research requests
sponsored by other u.s federal executive
branch agencies
or offices or institutions whatever the
designation might happen to be
but critically we are not government
employees
which puts us in a bit of a bind it
gives us many of the same constraints
that bls has and other agencies have
with adoption
adopting tools but uh but
the ben the challenge
that our email address isn't dot gov so
where there are solutions where a
gov email address would would get you
out of trouble
we're not privy to those we are a dot
org
federally funded research and
development centers if you're not
familiar with them
are a category in u.s code
they are intended to provide long-term
support
for research and development that
is in some way beyond what
normal contracting might get you
most people know several ffrdc's but may
not be aware that that's what the
organizations are
you've probably heard of the jet
propulsion laboratory los alamos
national labs
those are both ffrdc's as well
in our case we're supporting the white
house in their cases
nasa and department of energy
critically we get access to both
sensitive and proprietary data so we
we straddle uh government and private
sector
we have access we are
we have security clearances from dod
where granted access to government
information that's
uh for gov for official government use
only um
or classified but we also get access to
corporate data where that would be
useful to our analyses
information that government agencies
might not normally have
access to
there are a number of
answers on tasks that often demand
quick turnaround sometimes on the order
of hours
but many of our tasks run as long as a
year or two years
as well we're working on topics
where the answer probably isn't known if
it were known
we would not be the people to come to
we're working on cutting edge issues
where the landscape is still uncertain
and we're helping
agencies to understand what that
landscape and what the potential for
science
and technology investment might be
uh because we are uh working closely
with the federal government
that imposes on us some constraints on
the tools that we can use in line with
what was being described
uh previously
the national security and the and the
data um
privacy concerns all come into play for
us
even though we're not dot gov and
because of the kinds of rapid
turnarounds
that we're often asked to do we need to
be able to set up and tear down our data
analysis infrastructure
fairly quickly sometimes
we're often sandboxed the systems we're
working on might even be air gapped
meaning there are
no network connections available to
those machines period
and so it's whatever we can do on the
box that we have
or on the isolated network that we have
so imagine
a situation where you've been issued a
new computer you're not the
administrative user on that computer
you have no network access and you're
left trying to figure out how to
establish
your data analysis environment and how
to collaborate with other people who are
working on the analysis with you
that's the situation we're in often on a
daily basis
that begs a range of questions that are
really valuable to have answered but are
often
not well documented in the packages that
are available on cran
or on github um licensing terms
are are your packages appropriately
license licensable
uh by a not-for-profit organization that
happens to be working with government
um am i going to be able to install
configure and use those tools
or do you have dependencies in the
installation or the configuration
that require network access that can be
a problem for us
each new tool involves some technical
debt that we're
acquiring um we have to be really aware
of those things we have to be sensitive
to
to the debts that we're taking on so
that we don't build a stack
that is more like jenga than um a tower
of hanoi
um are the tools documenting their data
security handling
do you make it clear and transparent
when data is being transmitted out over
a network
connection do you attend the data
privacy concerns
and are you addressing sort of section
508
accessibility issues with your with the
tools that you're creating
um and critically for me how are the
results supposed to be communicated at
the end we'll say a little bit more
about each
of these as i go here so again
thinking about the licensing think about
a lot of the like the tools that you use
um particularly the ones that need to be
purchased uh we're not government so we
don't get the benefit of government
contracting
but we are paid by the government and so
we're making purchases with federal
dollars
most of our purchases are subject to the
federal acquisition regulations
we need to be able to certify the data
security and the accessibility
compliance of the tools that we're using
particularly
if the the tools are being used to
produce a data dashboard
that's either going to be made public or
it's going to be made available
within a government agency
so many things these days have gone to
subscription software subscription
models
that's a poor fit for us since we're
working on research contracts
the the contract that drives us to
choose a particular tool probably won't
be in existence six months or a year
from now
and so when that comes due for renewal
we're not in a position to charge to
that task any longer we're not in a
position to continue to support the
the license of that tool and
the reality is that if we're going to
adopt a tool if we're going to accept
the technical debt
then we probably also want to be able to
use the tool across multiple tasks which
for us means multiple government
sponsors
it just it makes licensing very
complicated
and think about all of those tools that
you use where the
the mechanism is to go to the website
log on to the page
put in your credit card number and pay
for it
as an end user within the organization
that's not an option for me i need to
collaborate with our finance
office to go through that kind of a
process
oh but the sign up will be very simple
we'll just send you an sms message
that can be challenging
so some things that we take into account
whenever we look at a new tool we are in
our shop
and we are reliant on our studio and not
just the tidy verse although i've used
just tidy verse hexes here but um
we our users may not be full
administrative users even if they are
quote unquote administrative users under
the the normal
concerns there may be some specific
windows permissions or user group
settings
that are customized for the national
security computing environment
where as end users we're not authorized
to sign ndas or
end user license agreements on behalf of
the organization we have to run those
through the
through the the corporate council's
office
so do you provide an easy way for us to
get those documents out of the software
so that they can be forwarded to
corporate counsel
and i'm not trying to call corporate
counsel and read them the licensing
terms uh over the phone
we're not authorized to act as
government employees so if you've
if you have particular set-asides that
allow the government to use
your tools do they apply to ffr dc's
something worth considering i i hope um
we're generally prevented from using
anything that depends on the cloud so if
i see a tool
a package or application that requires
uh cloud use
that generally disqualifies it from use
not absolutely but almost
um always if you have a
runtime requirement that the tool call
home
in order to register a license or verify
um authorization to use or retrieve
updates
that's going to be a problem if you have
just-in-time dependency installation as
so many tools do
right you run a new command and that
command says oh i also need this other
package
the fact that we might not find out
about that for days or months
and that once we do find out about it
we're in an isolated air gap environment
makes it very difficult for us to adopt
these tools so i'm coming
at every new tool with a very critical
eye
much like bls we need to get approval
for the specific versions of the tools
and all of its dependencies at the time
that we're going to install those tools
we have very limited ability to update
those tools certainly can't do it on
demand
you've probably run into a situation
where you've discovered a post on
stack overflow or um wherever
and uh the the suggested solution
is simply to disable security that's a
bug
for us that's that's not a fix that's
not a solution that we can adopt
um and more and more uh questions about
accessibility
are requirements not optional
considerations
so does your tool provide colorblind
safe color palettes and do you book do
you provide descriptions for the
graphics that you're
uh creating how easy do you make it
to uh to integrate accessibility
concerns
into the use of your tool
this is my therapy dragon's slide um
then magic happens we've gotten through
the setup we've managed to get through
all of the licensing we've gotten
through the configuration we have the
packages installed that we want to work
with
then you do your data science you
conduct your analysis and at the far end
of that
you have results that you want to convey
in some way
at least during this talk i'm not
worried about the analysis i'm worried
about
the before and the after so what are the
typical mechanisms these days by which
results are being communicated well
you can publish it to the web or to the
cloud in the ways that that's different
from the web
you can push a repo to github maybe you
can generate html and javascript files
that you can
uh email to someone or set upload to a
server or you can produce an executable
file
[Music]
or maybe a zip file that can be shared
except none of these are workable
solutions in
my environment in ffrdc
the first three it's not appropriate for
the kinds of government data that we're
working with
when we're dealing with controlled
unclassified information
cui used to be called fouo for official
use only
or when you're dealing with classified
information that's at the secret or the
top secret or above levels
those systems are isolated you're not
going to have access to those cloud
services
and html files executable files
compressed files
are all too likely attack vectors
um and so delivery to sponsors is
usually blocked for those things i can't
unless i put it on a physical media and
sneaker net it over
to a sponsor's office i don't usually
have the ability to
bring those kinds of things into their
environment and even if i can bring them
into their environment they may not have
the ability to plug in a usb stick
uh usb ports may be turned off they may
not have the ability to
launch an executable that hasn't been
verified by security
and so on and so on right and so what
are the typical delivery formats
well i hate to say it but microsoft word
excel powerpoint
with no macros and no vba active in them
are typical pngs for static images
and pdf files again with no macros
involved
or we can stand up on premises devices
so or services so we can't use github
but i can license the enterprise version
of bitbucket and stand up a bit bucket
server
within our firewall
so just to check your your thinking on
this these are some pretty common things
that one does when you're setting up a
new system with r you want to install r
well that requires
network access to download it you want
to install our studio
requires network access and keenly you
have to be an administrative user to
install
our studio on windows systems um
you want to install the tidyverse again
network access
and if any of the packages involved in
the tidyverse
are most we are the most recent version
of them
is um in source code on cran
sorry on github uh you may need to
compile those tools
from source that requires installation
of our tools
which requires that you have network
access and be an administrative user
and if you've gotten past all of that
you've gotten all those things installed
and you're in our studio the first time
you click that compose notebook button
or the knit document button
you need runtime access to download the
latest version of our markdown
and you need access to load down
download a
version of tech to be able to produce
pdfs
or word documents
maybe as we saw earlier in the day you'd
like to use fur or
future packages for parallelization
but those trigger network access
and so you have to have you have to be
an admin user to grant firewall access
to allow for the parallel computation to
happen
which means even if you have that it
means that you can't write standalone
self-running scripts that you're going
to have to be there to click the
authorize button
in order to get those parallelized
scripts to run
perhaps you'd like to do some geo work
using maps as we saw earlier today
well those packages typically require
network access to grab the map
tiles for the area that you want to plot
and if they're interactive maps
with something like leaflet you need
javascript access
for interactivity on the plot
shiny and rprez similar sorts of things
you may because they're
deployed using a local loopback you
might need administrative access to
grant that network access and again
runtime access to be able to download
javascript libraries
and don't things like shiny io github
amazon web services and so on those are
just out of scope
because of their cloud nature we have no
way of certifying their
security so
a big part of my job in building a data
analytics team when i bring in new
people
is to expose the assumptions that are
made about the tools we're using in
building people get very comfortable
we've gotten very
uh used to the idea that we just click a
button and it installs a new package on
our system and we're
we have a new capability and we're off
and running and we're not thinking in
the moment about whether that package
came from a reliable source we're not
thinking about whether that package
has underlying dependencies on cloud
services and so on so we need to bring
those to the surface
which often means getting people to step
back when there's a bright shiny new
version of something that's come out
and to think about those sorts of
underlying assumptions we have to manage
that the technical debt that comes along
with each of these new tools that we
adopt and ideally we want to be able to
contribute to the free and open source
software community even though we can't
necessarily give you a reproducible
example or
reproducible environment in which the
problems we run into
occur i can't tell you our networking
infrastructure i can only tell you that
your package has a problem under
certain networking infrastructures and
suggest a fix
and given that we're not able to access
most commercial cloud services how do we
then
conduct reproducible research and
communicate our results to our sponsors
so at the end of the day i hope what
you'll do is think about the packages
and the tools that you're using
and that some of you are developing
hopefully you'll have an opportunity to
inject these into conversations with
people who are responsible for
building the tools and documenting the
tools to think about
these kinds of issues so what
assumptions are we making i come
from academia originally so i tend to
think about what are we doing with our
training what do we
what what are our assumptions when we're
training our data science students
um that setup is quick and easy and
everything can just be done in
on a server in the cloud is the first
assumption i think we often take
what are the assumptions we're making
when we're building new tools
what assumptions are we making about our
end users and what capabilities and
permissions
they have on their systems and what
assumptions are we making about the
compute environments
that our analysis tools need to operate
in
ideally we would be intentional and
explicit about the dependencies that we
have
and choose between those things that are
absolutely necessary for what we're
doing and those things that are just
nice to have features and somehow factor
those out
we will be explicit about the security
implications of the tools
that we're developing and explicit about
the accessibility issues
that come along with the tools that
we're using
i provide a few resources for anyone
who's interested in reading up on either
ffrdc's the complete text of the
law that establishes the authority for
ffrdc's is provided there
information on the national archives and
records administration and the
presidential records act which are the
kinds of things that prevent for example
acceptance of zip files
by certain administrations by certain
offices
and then us a run of accessibility
related
websites and articles dating back a few
years
about the kinds of features in software
and in programming languages
it's worth noting here the third item
rstudio has done a phenomenal job the
last year year and a half
in bringing accessibility features into
our studio
if you are not familiar with those
accessibility features i highly
recommend that you take a look at them
accessibility tends paying attention to
accessibility tends to expose a lot of
interesting insight about the
communication and visualization and
rendering of data in other non-visual
formats
that um that can make all of our data
products
better i believe great yes thank you so
much for showing us all the hurdles and
obstacles
you have to go through i really want to
pack in both you and wendy in there
to our show the the challenges of
software and team building
in uh in the federal space i know
different agencies have different
different ways of getting around this so
uh you know thank you for showing us all
that
uh first update on twitter